calling in right now is one of our
favorites we haven't spoken to him in a
while
uh the man who does football morning in
america must read column every single
day on nbc sports joining us peter king
here on the rich eisen show how you
doing pk
rich i do want to ask you one question
before we start on all things please get
full please sir um
have you told your lovely bride susie
what you guys are going to be doing for
new year's eve
oh yeah we're we're we're uh last
in all like honesty since you have asked
uh as jim harbaugh was lifting the
trophy
um i turned to sue's uh it could have
been
uh mere seconds to say uh we're gonna
have to find a television on new year's
eve that's gonna have to
happen she knew it but she knows she's
this is even though it's all of our
first rodeo with this whole michigan
being uh in the national champions
semifinal thing i mean um it's it's all
good man i it's house money as far as
i'm concerned it's unbelievable did you
see the the sort of cute uh
brady harbaugh thing that brady posted
last week i did not with
oh it was really good it was about him
talking about
uh how great it was to finally see
michigan beat ohio state and recounting
the times he beat him and how low he was
when he lost to him
uh it was really really good he was on
some um some video deal with harbaugh
and they and they posted a clip of it it
was fun yeah i'm i'm i'm on cloud nine
and i appreciated your text as well that
you sent me over the weekend i'm getting
texts from people like literally i
played you know what i mean
it's it's funny but um i appreciate it
so uh let us jump in uh to the the nfl
and i know that they're they're on a buy
and i know that they are on the outside
looking in or as we refer to it here on
the rich eisen show sniffing it in the n
and the nfc but what happened with
carolina they fire offensive coordinator
joe brady who came with matt rule in a
very heralded maneuver by the
organization as the best hottest
coaching candidate from college and the
best hottest coordinator candidate from
college and pairing them up what
happened
i think brady's reputation was a little
bit shaky
coming into this year uh rich
because i think the panthers were a
little surprised that he couldn't make
beautiful music with teddy bridgewater
last year in fact at the end of last
year i'm told that brady expected that
he was going to get fired after last
year
and he didn't they kept him in
and
basically i think
what it all means
is that uh he wasn't calling the game
that the head coach wanted to be called
the head coach wants to be a little bit
more ground and pound
uh than joe brady wanted it to be and so
rather than continuing
to try to deal with this
put a square peg in a round hole he just
made a change
i think he almost did brady a favor by
doing it on an nfl game day sunday
so the news would be dwarfed by the
white noise of all the games huh
so
carolina again like the saints like
other teams that are on the outside look
looking in
uh still have five games left to play to
make a run and they're not too far away
from that playoff spot so they're not
going to be making a run
well then the question is like what are
they going to look like so that it's
going to be tuba hubbard and
and and
cam doing mesh point stuff and trying to
jam it down your throat and trying to
make that run that you say they're not
going to make i mean i mean who knows
rich i mean
i think the bottom line in all of this
in all of this is you look at every
coach who is struggling right now
everyone
and there is a universal truth
they don't have a quarterback
and you know they can they can dress it
up any way they want to in carolina in
the last five weeks
do you really have hope that at the end
of that five-week period
that david pepper and matt rule are
going to have a meeting and they're
going and and scott fitter and they're
gonna have a meeting and say yep cam's
our guy going forward
that was a six million dollar scotch
tape job till the end of the year
and then they're gonna go out and spend
more money and try to fix it one more
time
and chase the tail
that is every team knowing that it will
never win without getting a quarterback
in the future
does ron rivera have a quarterback of
the future as has taylor heineke played
his way into being the washington
football team whatever they'll be known
but it's why
you know it's good that you've got five
more games to make that judgment and
maybe a postseason game
i could see a scenario where
washington drafts the best quarterback
available when it picks in the draft
this year
or
uh
you know if there's one in the second or
third round do they really like
and then just bring him to camp and let
him learn and give taylor heinecke
another year to see if he's a long-term
guy
but
i mean
maybe
he's the kind of guy who you want on
your roster it's exactly like why do you
want colt mccoy why do you want gardner
minchu because you want competent
uh or better than competent level nfl
backup on your team
so what about minshew
did that uh do anything move the needle
in any way shape or form and in
philadelphia
i mean they never traded for gardner
minshew
basically gardner minshew is you know
replaced joe flacco
and they're both six round picks
uh
you know that was the compensation for
him
so
that there's there's i i shouldn't say
there's no way it's highly highly
unlikely that howie roseman woke up this
morning and said well jalen hurts
gartner minchu going into 2022.
you know they've got they probably will
have three
first-round picks
somewhere between let's say
12 and 25
and you're going to be able to do a lot
with that uh maybe between 10 and 25 and
you're going to be able to do a lot with
that so
we'll see what happens i don't think
they're done building their quarterback
roster peter king here on the rich eisen
show and here we are now week 13 longest
regular season ever etcetera and so on
and so forth and the pre-season
uh non-playing season
talent evaluation season the
conversation was all of uh about russell
wilson
and him wanting better or him wanting a
voice or him wanting stuff that we saw
brady
cash in right and that was the whole
conversation now here we are they just
finally won a game with him as
quarterback for the first time since
week four uh peter that happened where
do things stand uh over the next few
weeks uh as they are probably are in the
same category of hoping to make a run
but perhaps not making it what do you
think
i think the next few weeks for for pete
carroll are vitally important for his
future
um i won't be surprised if they make a
coaching change but i don't think
they're actively looking to make a
coaching change
um
i do believe that jody allen is
uh
you know certainly has to be thinking
about that and thinking about what she
wants the future of her franchise to be
and look rich i don't know this for a
fact but it's just a feeling i get
i think if if pete carroll comes back
just my gut feeling that russell wilson
would probably want to
have a chance to play elsewhere
it's not that he doesn't like pete
carroll i think he does like pete
carroll
but you know he wants different he wants
a change he wants something new
and i think that new could be a new
situation in seattle we'll see but again
a lot of that
is going to have to do with what happens
in these in this last month of the
season
so many teams right now i think are on
the cusp
like seattle
like denver i think denver is a really
fascinating place to watch because
obviously they've now lost 11 in a row
to their daddies
in the
afc west kansas city
so what do you do if you're denver
you really like vic fangio you like what
he does on defense
you simply cannot get the quarterback
position right it's been six years now
so what do you do
and that's the thing i think that george
payton has to decide there and i think
in in seattle they have to decide
do we want russell wilson to be the
centerpiece of our of our future if so
with what coach
and uh
you know how active are we going to be
in trying to improve our team in the off
season and how active is russell going
to be in that decision right
well he certainly rattled a couple of
cages
liz springs if i were jody allen if i
were john schneider now jody allen's a
bit of a reclusive person
uh if i were jody allen and john
schneider i would uh i would probably
have him a little bit involved i would
probably have some discussions with him
before the end of this year like rich
the scenario i think if i were
if i were ruling the world if i were
running the seahawks
is
i'd have a meeting with russell wilson
if i were jody allen and i would just
say hey this is all off the record
nothing's coming out of this room
but i just want to know do you want to
be here if you want to be here what are
the conditions that you'd be a happy
willing
long-term participant here
that's what you ought to do you
shouldn't be going to war with your
quarterback every year not saying that
they will be
but i do think that if it's status quo
at the end of the year
i'm not sure russell wilson is going to
want to stay
that's fine you both made your decision
but you really ought to just lay the
cards on the table uh you know before
you get to nut cutting time peter king
here on the rich eisen show what is the
steelers plan at quarterback do you
think
what do you think
i really don't think they have one um i
think they i think they're going to
enter the off-season
um i would be very surprised everybody
always says hey steelers this
conservative organization
all this well
they've made some big moves that maker
fits patrick trade everybody said oh my
god that's so unstealer like
kevin colbert is really smart he's more
of a progressive guy
than people think more of a future
thinker than people think and when it
comes to quarterback i will be
very surprised
if they don't pick up the phone after
the season after ben roethlisberger
walks away which
i thought it was very interesting adam
schefter has the story saturday
roethlisberger has the chance
to to
deny it or to say it isn't true and all
he says is
well i haven't told everybody that and
everybody chuckles so clearly this is a
story this is real
and
to me
when i hear that when i think about it
i think
two days after the last game of the
season for the green bay packers
just my gut feeling kevin colebrook's
going to pick up the phone and call
brian gooda
and say do not make a move on aaron
rodgers if you're going to without
talking to us
you know and and then that the question
is
is
why why wouldn't rogers want to stay put
you know what i mean like
what they really what are the packers
going through are they what about
devonta adams well that's what i'm
saying but why would the packers say you
know what it's time for us to just start
from square one with
jordan love right we've got the coach
he's not going anywhere and we've got
the rest of the roster that we totally
believe but we do need to just start
from scratch
rather than do that three years from now
when aaron rodgers might want to walk
away at age 42 43 like
and then why would roger unless rogers
really feels that um that that
everything hasn't been done for him or
does it really matter the way the season
finishes
than what we're talking about because
rogers is in a spot where he knows he
knows exactly where everything is and
what
what he wants but i think i think it
matters i think everything matters to
aaron rodgers
look
i don't know that everybody believes
this and i can't tell you i don't live
in aaron rodgers head
but when i talked to him in august he
looked me in the eye and he said listen
this right now
is about this season this is about being
where your feet are this is not about
thing he told the team this when he came
back
and i'm gonna i'm gonna crudely
paraphrase because i i wasn't there but
this is just basically what he passed on
to me
that he told his teammates listen
forget worrying about where you're going
to be in 2022. forget about the future
let's everybody do everything humanly
possible we can to win
now
to win this year
and then next year's gonna take care of
itself forget it and so i don't think
he's gonna talk about it i'd be
surprised if he talked about it at all
and i think he just wants to let
everything
fall the way it's going to fall this
year and then
on february 16th
or whatever the morning after his last
game is of course he thinks about it now
but that's when he will really start to
put his plan into place
for 2022 and beyond and just as a
reminder rich
aaron rodgers has the ability after this
year to request a trade
and green bay has to uh
you know has to deal him then okay
he'll have some choice but not full
choice as to where he goes
and then if he if he plays one more year
in 2022
he will be an unrestricted free agent
right and the packers can do nothing to
stop him from leaving so
essentially
he can go next year with some strings on
him including keep this in mind wherever
he goes it's going to cost that team two
or three very high draft picks and maybe
one very good player if he goes to
denver two for two ones and jerry judy
like is he going to say whoa whoa whoa
whoa i want to throw the ball to jerry
judy you know so
so there there's a lot of things i'm
sure he is thinking about now and he
will think about but i don't think any
of us are going to be privy to that
until after the season isn't it amazing
how the patriots have gotten it right so
quickly now that we're talking about
quarterbacks they're turning the page
and what to do and great lesson isn't it
it's a great lesson in saying
we're going to tune out all the noise
we're gonna pick with the 15th pick in
the draft a quarterback who we think is
ready made
not just for our offense but for being a
new england patriot he walked in there
the same way tom brady walked in there
in 2000 which is
oh you know having having no privileges
even though he was the 15th pig in brady
199th
having no privileges and having to prove
absolutely everything
and you know they've they've kept them
under a rock for the most part
uh i've requested and been unable to
interview them i'm sure a lot of my
peers in that same house too experience
that's the way belichick is to rookies
uh he's like he's got the john thompson
ethos
you know that john thompson used to have
with freshmen
but but i i look at this right now rich
and i just say
belichick built this team the absolute
right way for a young quarterback how
intermediate throwing targets hunter
henry johnny smith
and with defensive play makers that
every week it's somebody new one week
kyle van noy one week kyle duggar one
week jc jackson one week
matt judon i mean it's amazing
how many defensive play makers they have
and everybody said oh geez you're giving
away stefan gilmore
i mean as usual belichick knew what he
was doing
and it's funny you say that you know
jones enters the same way that brady
entered even though brady was a a
sixth-round pick 199th overall mac jones
was a first-rounder 15. uh we we all
know that there's a famous documentary
the brady six uh because there were six
quarterbacks taken before him mac jones
despite where he was there were four
taken before him so we can maybe have a
documentary the jones four at some point
it's all hey hey you know what rich rich
great moral to the story
and i remember there's a quarterback
who's been picked in the top five
i'm not gonna tell you in the last three
or four years
whose agent was bemoaning where he was
going to go and who was going to pick
him
and i said to him you know lamar
jackson's the luckiest guy in the world
because i'm sure he was angry on draft
day going at the absolute bottom of the
first round
but he should have been throwing a party
just like dan marino threw a party or
should have been when he got picked 28th
by the dolphins
because it is
your first contract in football just
doesn't matter
it's where you're drafted
and what your chances are once you're
drafted
and look on draft night everybody is
happy zach wilson's happy justin fields
happy trevor lawrence they're all happy
but i i will tell you do you think any
of those guys
don't now look at mac jones and say oh
my god
what a great situation he's in what a
lucky
guy he is
i i mean you know it's where you get
drafted
peter thanks for the call loved it as
always appreciate it okay rich you take
care peter king check out his football
morning in america colin hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here